he kept the legs off the jockstrap so
you just wait you wore a jockstrap the
best boxing love-story having to grind
her leg
oh my god never mind I'll find someone
like you
we wish nothing but the best
[Music]
how did this happen I mean what's how
did it happen are you kidding me he's
336 and one I love that's how it
happened I just I need to remind people
Bill Belichick would need to lose 1070
games in a row to have a worse winning
percentage than huge that's a great stat
good job yeah I like the night it's a
shame but it's still insane
welcome to Simpson left go that was the
news of the weekend but there's a lot of
stuff going on this week and it is time
for mid-season Awards
[Music]
for our mid-season Awards we're not
doing MVP play award no we have our own
style and first we're doing best player
no one's talking about in the first half
who you go I'm gonna go with Cam Newton
I mean he's the quarterback of a five
and two football team okay he does not
get the respect he deserves because he
doesn't throw for four hundred yards and
five touchdowns every week but I will
say this trying to defend him can't
quantified sometimes left guy how does
the worst phrase of the first half of
the season I'm gonna go deeper cut yeah
I'm going Frank Clark of the Seattle
Seahawks when the league leaders and
sacks and every time I watch the
Seahawks game the quarterback is running
for his life
yeah from Franklin I mean how cancel I
mean nobody gives Cam respect all right
next up good bad good award people that
were good that they were bad and they
are good I believe this should be called
the Ryan Fitzpatrick award I am giving
it to Ryan Fitzpatrick okay it is
synonymous and with not just his career
but also this season yeah he was
incredible and then he disappeared and
then he's back again and it's amazing
who you go I'm gonna go with D forward
in the Kansas City Chiefs
give me the first round pick okay kind
of had a decent start to his career and
then everyone's like who is this guy
he's horrible he became an internet meme
yes and now he's the best player on the
Kansas City defense I like that one all
right so everyone's gonna focus on coach
of the year we know that the real money
is made with coordinator right which
coordinator do you want to give shine
his best coordinator in the first half
Greg mineski defensive coordinator for
the Washington Redskins number four
defense in football and all anybody
remembers about the year is the Monday
night game against drew Brees after a
bye week yeah they laid an egg that week
but other than that they've been
phenomenal and there's not a lot of
superstars on that deep and they're
number two against rushing there you go
it's pretty amazing right I have to give
an apology and no word Norv Turner I am
sorry I made fun of you this offseason
and said you hired your entire family
tree for your coaching staff and that
you quit on Mike Zimmer in Minnesota and
you've proven me wrong sir wait itself
Scott you're five and to Carolina
Panthers Cam Newton this offense a
little bit of this a little bit of that
a little bit of apology yep I'm sorry
nor for the men now the most important
award for our midseason extravaganza the
best player that people think Sims hates
okay
Jared Goff that would be the guy that I
think definitely think hey Jeff yeah
they really do and I'll say you know I
definitely was skeptical about him
coming into the year but again it's the
place he makes that aren't there that I
think are extremely impressive
scrambling people around the pocket big
throws down the back he deserves credit
I think the the player that people think
you hate that's playing the best is Matt
Ryan and I would say it's been a year
and a half of Matt Ryan playing the best
football of his career I and it's the
team carried him early in his career
yeah he's carrying the team right now
agree with that and you don't hate Matt
Ryan I don't hate Matt at all you know
who else you don't hate what Brian
Urlacher who I know what Brian Urlacher
hated but being put into a box put into
a box well who would like to be in a box
apparently the Chicago Bears the best
boxing love story happened to Brian
Urlacher the greatest one we created
this games that was called box him up
because everybody got like Nike and
Reebok shoes and different things in
clothes and then you'd have the boxes a
couple boxes left over so people will be
walking and if they're not paying
attention you just run up behind him and
slam the box over the head right and say
box him up so everybody had to have
their head on the swivel
locker room so Brian was really good at
getting other people to cuz he's sneaky
yeah like you get you coming out of your
meeting room or some and boom you got a
box slammed over your head he would get
so many people that yeah everybody kind
of had it out for you everybody turned
on here's the box bully yeah
you don't it took me once you get boxed
on once I'm like you're getting ahead of
me
like literally around the locker room
you got your back to the wall yeah I'm
keeping everybody in front of it I think
the d-line brainstorms on like would be
the best way to try to get them enemies
it's Bill's brilliant I'm imagining the
deal I'm doing like a space shuttle
launch yeah they probably had like
protractors and all kind of stuff you
know these are electric so you gotta get
yes right I don't know how they got this
box wheels like a 6 foot box in an our
locker room there's stairs to go to the
second floor while the cardio stuff is
and there's a platform so you can't see
who's up there so he comes out and so
right when he walks out from under the
platform somebody drops that six foot
box right on his head
his arms down it dropped like straight
over he's like look in the box
everybody's like box him up all you saw
was two little feet like kicking out a
little box this is a special moment for
me
this is somebody that I love with all of
my heart Brian Westbrook don't give him
your cell phone then clinger over here
we just heard Matt Forte talking about
pranks Eagles locker room you trot T Oh
McNabb Freddie Mitchell all those guys
any pranks come to mind right away you
named him Freddie Mitchell always me I'm
not sure that he ever practiced or did
anything with meetings but he loves
pranks and won this is a small win so
you got when you put your jockstrap on
ready to play he cooked the the legs off
the jockstrap so you just just had that
just banging like that wasn't the worst
way wait you were a jock strap is horse
man Dex I know I needed another Cup but
they don't work Josh I need I didn't
know didn't they're secure we're all
secure here man man the other thing is
he was on the bucks his spleen explode
sorry for bringing it up that's our and
like a few games later you guys go down
to Tampa Bay and you had one of the
greatest plays I've ever seen that no
one will remember we were up by about 20
you were up big furious comeback and
that was my first experience seeing this
guy right it'll dump off like 50 60
yards weaved in and out yeah break a
couple Michaels make some guys miss and
kind of strut into the end zone with
only a minute left there's no way no way
Tampa Bay is gonna get the the return
right and return it right correct
starting quarterbacks not in there Sims
ISM there so there's no exactly exactly
and then Matt Bryant kicked that 62 yard
field goal for the buck so you were
filled with joy he was filled with I was
first filled with amazement it was my
first time that I was on a field with
him and got to see him pull some of
these plays off that he did in the
fourth quarter
yeah and he's ahead of his time at that
position agree you know now I feel like
there's a lot of guys like you around
the NFL and that's the first place like
who's the guy you look at in the NFL
right now that you're
amazed by or you reminds you of you at
running back miss a couple guys I mean
jerk McKinnon I would that was they were
gonna use him did they use my office
than Paul he gets injured to Rico in
these last month of the season they
continue to use him more more James
White Dion Lewis same type of guy
something happened on Sunday I thought
of you immediately was there Todd Gurley
takes the ball runs down slides right
there on the one-yard line
no touchdown fantasy players are going
nuts Vegas is going crazy you did that
to Dallas
you know I've and of course I admire
with Todd girl continues to do week in
and week out and having done that in
against the Cowboys years ago I wish you
would have scored because I'm all about
fantasy now when I was playing it wasn't
about fantasy nothing now I'm all like
listen score as much as much as you can
as often as you can
I need it for my teammates I was up
against Curley and I was like you sit
down Paul was the point that if they
score the touchdown and maybe miss the
extra point which we see all the time
it's gonna be an eight-point lead and
you're still gonna give Aaron Rodgers
the ball back so true did you want to
play with that kind of fire I wouldn't
know in hindsight now retired and not
having to worry about so much ways for
it I know people love it people
especially people in Philly they love to
play yeah everywhere else they're like
what are you doing I was gonna go to
Andy Reed well that's exactly where I
want to go to just what he's doing there
he's got a one lost team with Patrick
mahomes do you have joy watching this
happen I have so much joy I mean I love
Andy as a coach as a man certainly a guy
that I looked up to and appreciate
everything he did for my career quick
story when we got Mike Vick I talked to
Andy and he was like I've been drawing a
plays on napkins for Vick just to get
him in the game get him the football
that's what he's constantly doing
thinking of different plays and I can't
imagine what he's thinking about now
yeah right he'll wanna go Kelsey right
Hawkins hunt I mean any as a quarterback
now that wants to let it go so I mean to
me that's like a joystick
Madden game type of offense out there
what is it that the players love about
Andy Reid some coaches say hey Westbrook
you know I just didn't do his job today
and he should have did this and did that
kind of makeup for show the media and
the fans like who was wrong
suddenly throw something out of the bus
I want to show you what's the deal and
Andy was never like that he would always
say I have that in the media in
Philadelphia hated it yes but when
you're a player you love it
because that means your coach has your
back no he still told you about yourself
he'd still plenty to out on film within
the building but he kept everything
inside of the building and he was great
with that last part ulama thank you
what's up I'm Avery Williamson you're
watching The Sims and left oh so it's
Niners it's Raiders it's Homer cast on
Thursday Night Football in the house
that Jim Tomsula built I'm out of love
go Raiders reporter and let's bring in
the likely vegan that often smells like
beans Chris Simms hey there Chris well
that was a nice shot you took at our
brand-new Stadium but at least we can
afford one black hole more like crap
hole just because we have a baseball
diamond and we have multiple interest
doesn't mean we should be punished and
by the way we found a beautiful new
place to settle down somehow that's
right leave in town once again because
we know who runs this area it's the
49ers and our five Super Bowl trophies
Montana rice eat that Oakland how many
of those players is Kyle Shanahan on his
team and by the way how is old Kyle
doing this year 1 and 7 that's gotta
hurt that you should talk you're 1 in 6
and at least our head coach can afford a
cool haircut and your owner he's got a
little issue in that department as well
if we're gonna talk about appearances
it's kind of interesting that your
current quarterback CJ Beathard looks
like a bagger at Trader Joe's he plays
like one too sometimes Chris well I
can't deny that but we're looking
forward to 2019 when Jimmy Garoppolo
gets healthy bwaah we have three
first-round picks and the future's
bright Sims Oh bright like the Las Vegas
Strip next to Britney Spears that's
great you're so good with first-round
picks left go yeah you really are I mean
Darius hey we're Bay JaMarcus Russell
uh Robert gallery they told you please
don't mention Jamarcus you guys it's oh
you stink too I know I don't even know
why people are watching this hey let's
go watch young Sheldon that's far on
somebody in left Co we've had four
people we're up a little bit more than
four hundred dollars and it's time for
our ninth pick of the season somebody in
left
is a success this time New York City
won't let grace make a pick watch so my
name is Adam and this is grace and she's
a singer/songwriter and we've tried to
do this like 12 times for this coffee
shop but we've had cursing people a
woman walked through it's been wild
here's a deal not the biggest NFL fan
you've been to a few Titans games how'd
they do they lost
I've never been to a Titans game where
they won Thursday night it is the Niners
versus the Raiders the Niners have to
win by three and a half what do you know
about both of these teams I don't know
much about either team but I do know the
Raiders black and silver
there's Oakland yes yeah so do you feel
more comfortable because you know them
yeah it's time yeah familiar with that
team are you willing right now to
guarantee Raiders overnighters yes it's
official
yeah if you win I'm back with the money
next week oh man please come on by
joining somebody and left go come on
come on in
yes that's somebody left go this is
great she's picking the Raiders yeah
have a great day New York City all right
here's the deal
we're doing a prank just left Co and you
guys so it is the trade deadline we're
recording this on Tuesday and we thought
we'd fire up Photoshop and convince Sims
that Odell is being traded to the Texans
I think it's gonna work even better
we're in full costume because it's
Halloween look at this
[Laughter]
dangerous how do you feel as a brunette
negative ghostrider the pattern is full
oh my god oh my god I think you're lying
no oh my god yesterday right
Oh BJ was traded to the Texans hold my
god are you guys seeing this
yeah bro bro yo bro Football Talk O'Dell
poor game games and have a heart attack
dude my Super Bowl pic the Texans I mean
I love that we set it on the pot
yesterday
hold on them all right Lee what did he
get what do they get for him a first and
a second and Houston will also get a
sick only a first at a second all right
that's pretty good
no they had to take the salary into
account man dude damn they might be my
new favorite team Wow
do we change the whole show gosh damn
what did we talk about in the opening I
don't know you yeah
you know what's crazy as your first
guess was right Houston no my first
guess was like yeah this ain't real bro
you just got pranked on Halloween are
you kidding me you yes
okay did you know this game everybody
knew who guys everybody knew how did you
do
yes I like a huge pro football talk to
make it real to see I know let go though
you see that he doesn't do this
I know his tales like I have a full
house still go for it though still fall
for it if I really did it gosh I'm gonna
I'm gonna put all of you in headlocks
and one by one all right let's keep
going oh my god I just send in pictures
of your beautiful children for NFL kids
dressed up like quarterbacks or coaches
or players here's little Patrick mahomes
what a cutie holy moly that's awesome
Oh Grob it's awesome let's keep this bad
boy Oh Chucky feel like the same haircut
as Chucky Wow Wow
that kid is a special human being right
there cute and really knows his football
I didn't know we could find a Chris Sims
Jersey that could fit a kid that's very
true him I am so happy that we got you
fam you really did like I didn't I can't
believe it I was really just sitting
here thinking like man the Houston
Texans are those three this is gonna be
amazing
DeSean and Hopkins and Odell what you
know else is amazing
Brady plays Rogers at Sunday Night
Football yes everyone knows that you
would take Rogers over Brady yeah
they're both in your top three yeah so
don't send any 8 now what are we gonna
see man what is this gonna be like well
I think we're gonna see okay the New
England Patriots try to take away Aaron
Rodgers best target individual atoms we
know that they're gonna try to contain
Rodgers in the pocket cuz a lot of the
great plays he makes sure when he dances
around and moves yes so that's the thing
unfortunately it's gonna be Rogers
having to make magic which is always my
problem story miss powers and then we're
gonna see New England on the other side
ding ding ding ding touchdown right is
Brady's gonna execute and be on target
throwing footballs all over the field a
lot of basketball fans say one of the
greatest crying shames is that Kobe and
LeBron never faced off in a championship
right I would say that Rogers and Brady
never facing in a Super Bowl is worse
yes because Rogers against Belichick in
the Super Bowl with Brady on the other
side well if they caught that onside
kick and
Seattle yeah and then the Marshawn Lynch
thing never would have happened the
interception by Malcolm Butler right
who knows dented uh unbelievable that's
it that's it yeah good job ace for
maverick peace out homies I am the a CEV
EMT you are a man
we will holla at you next week enjoy the
games I can't do it this man okay okay I
can't get trolled how do you think goose
and Ace Ventura we're doing a comp it
together like this what does hey what's
up homies thanks for watching subscribe
to the B our YouTube channel man you're
such a millennial also while you're here
we have a lot other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close